so I'm juicy falero I'm a finally a PhD
student at Yale and I'm gonna talk about
addressing the parallelism gap in
replicated service systems so this talk
is divided into four parts
in the first part I'll go into some
background on multicores
and replication in the second part I'll
describe log shipping based replication
I'll then talk about a solution to the
parallelism gap which is mentioned in
the title and finally I'll give a little
detail on the implementation challenges
in implementing this solution okay so
let's just drive straight into
background on multi-core and replication
so driven by hardware and applications a
server code today has two important
requirements the first is that it must
exploit multi-core parallelism and the
second is that it must support high
availability via replication so in any
given deployment of server code we're
going to marry solutions to both these
sort of requirements together they need
to coexist
so multi-core Hardware today is now
increasingly accessible it's easily
accessible in the cloud where Amazon
provides ec2 instances with 128 virtual
CPUs it's easily accessible on-premise
where systems with more than 50 cores
have been widely available for several
years now so given that this given that
this parallel hardware is widely
available we want to have we want to
make use of it in our server code and
this has led to sort of we have a lot of
advances in programming multi-core
machines today programming models such
as futures and transactional memory are
slowly making their way into mainstream
languages and we have better
synchronization mechanisms like scalable
locks and Locker algorithms so in order
to take advantage of multi course server
code just you know it has to use the
right programming abstractions we the
the facilities are there today at the
same time our server code also needs to
be highly available as many of you
probably are aware this is because
availability is money and any losses in
availability can have a catastrophic
impact on revenue and Trust
and sort of the standard way to achieve
high availability is via replication
instead of having a single server
sitting there and like dealing with
requests from clients you instead sort
of use redundancy so this redundancy
makes applications highly available
because when a primary server goes down
you have a backup that can take over and
start processing requests from clients
right and this minimizes application
downtime and increases availability so
requests which update a server State are
typically executed against a primary
right and the primary logs these puts
these updates into a log and this log is
shipped out to a backup right and the
backup the whole point of replication is
that a backup should be an exact copy of
the primary via by sort of playing back
this log that shipped to it I mean this
is really important right it needs to be
an exact copy because if it's not an
exact copy then it doesn't have any hope
of being able to service requests from
clients if the primary goes down for
whatever reason so at this point it
seems like it's pretty easy to marry
these two requirements right because one
doesn't seem to influence the other in
any way they seem like two completely
orthogonal problems so we can get
multi-core parallelism by leveraging
parallel programming abstractions and
good synchronization mechanisms and we
can do replication by syncing servers by
sort of shipping these logs around
unfortunately it turns out that marrying
the two is complicated due to non
determinism parallel programs are
non-deterministic if you're building a
multi-threaded server then threads can
acquire locks in arbitrary orders if
you're using a futures library then the
order in which your promises return
results may vary across application runs
probably the most famous example of non
determinism in parallel code are
Heisenberg's so just get an
understanding of how many if you
actually understand or know about this
non determinism show quick show of hands
for who's heard about Heisenberg's
awesome this is perfect perfect audience
okay
so Heisenberg's are bugs in parallel
programs that are difficult to diagnose
because they do not deterministically
reproduce given the exact same input
right in this big spiral programs really
difficult to debug yet we need
determinism for replication right in any
replicated system but we I just said
that backups need to be exact copies of
primaries so that now this presents a
problem because given the exact same
input which of the log if we're not sure
if the replicas will actually come out
with the state that's exactly the same
that's sort of existed on the primary so
this is a really big problem because the
parallel programming techniques would
potentially allow replicas to diverge so
at this point I just wanted to clarify
the assumptions I'm going to make in
this talk how many of you of you out of
the cap theorem okay how many of you
you've heard about multi master
replication great okay okay if you put
your hand up just forget about the cap
theorem and multi master replication it
has nothing to do with this talk so
don't don't worry about it it's not
important for the books in this talk so
the replication mechanism that we're
going to talk about today is primary
backup replication in which backups keep
in sync with primaries via log shipping
and in a primary backup replicated
system the primary is typically
responsible for executing requests which
update application state right and up
and request which read application state
can be serviced by by both primaries and
backups in log shipping based
replication protocols or the effects of
updates as I mentioned before are put
into a log and this log is then shipped
to backups which apply the log to
reconstruct state of the primary so an
ID now dive into some details of log
shipping and why exactly doesn't gel
with parallel programming so logs
basically serve as a record of what
happened on the primary right so um you
if you basically want to reconstruct the
state of the primary by replaying this
log and the order of
records matters right playing rock
playing log records sequentially is
always guaranteed to be correct let's
look at what that might look like in the
context of an example so we have these
four requests which are sequentially
ordered in the log and the black box
there is the actual state of the
application so when we execute the first
request it updates x and y 2 x 1 y 1 the
second request updates the value of Z 2
Z to the third requests update the value
of y and z 2 y 3 and Z 3 and finally the
fourth request updates the value of W 2
W 4 right so we end up with this state
when we sequentially execute these log
records so now like let's look at
example of what could happen if we
executed these requests out of order so
let's say we first execute request 1
it changes the state of X and y2 x1 and
y1 and now instead of executing request
two we execute the quest 3 right so in
this case request 3 changes the state of
y and z 2 y 3 and Z 3 and request two
now changes the value of Z 2 Z 2 now
this point it's clear that the two
states are different right they've
diverged then this is because we've
executed the log records out of order
now the reason that this is real now the
reason this is this is a relevant for
parallel log replay is due to the non
determinism as I mentioned before so the
tip typically the way that you paralyze
these things is to associate a lock with
every object in your system so the lock
will prevent multiple writers from sort
of executing their updates concurrently
so it will ensure that only one writer
in a time at a time can execute updates
so in this case we know that requests 2
and 3 conflict right they both request a
lock on object Z but the lock doesn't
actually it doesn't actually guarantee
that request 2 gets the lock before
request 3 it could turn out that on a
particular run request 3 gets the lock
before request 2 and as a consequence
this is bad because like as we just saw
if we execute request 3 before request -
you may end up with divergent state so
as a consequence of these problems with
parallel replication log shipping
protocols often just resort to executing
logs si
really right the first obvious
limitation of this is that you can't
exploit a multi-core parallelism to
really log records right but that's
that's that's a small concern the
biggest concern is that the primary now
can execute requests in parallel but the
but the backups can only execute
requests sequentially so as a
consequence the rate at which of the
primary can produce these log records
far outpaces the rate at which a
replicas the backup can consume them and
this is really bad it can lead to some
very serious problems one of the
problems is that it can lead to
unbounded replication lag the problem is
that like since we're pursuing the
primary is going so far ahead of the
replicas at a much higher rate it's you
don't have any hope of the replicas ever
catching up with the primary in fact the
gap between the primary and the replicas
gets worse over time
second replicas can't really be used so
queries because they're too stale right
the problem is now that like if you if
you redirect a client to a replica it
may serve data that is you know really
stale in comparison to what exists on
the primary finally this slow
replication might even impact
availability this is because whenever
you need to fail over from a primary to
a backup the backup needs to first
synchronize to the most current state of
the primary as of the time it died and
this process is really slow so this has
an immediate impact on availability
right and this then is a consequence of
this there are several systems out there
that execute logs serially or newest
usually these include my sequel in
Postgres sequel and if you go read the
documentation in forums it's also a
problem in no sequel type systems such
as MongoDB and you don't have to take my
word for this like here's an excerpt
from a blog post by Percona
which is a my sequel consulting and
support company this is an excerpt it
says the first glaring problem with my
sequel is single threaded replication it
is severe and getting much worse as
servers get more and more CPU cores the
replication process executes in a single
thread on the replicas and thus has no
hope of ever keeping up with the primary
even on a moderately busy workload
here's another example of booking.com so
this is taken from a slide deck that
they gave a talk about parallel
application one or two years ago so they
say that parallel application is new
because it is hard it is hard because of
data consistency running transactions in
parallel you need to get the same
results on all your backups and this
result must be equivalent to what
existed on the primary so given the
background for this problem and now dive
into what a solution might look like so
before we do that let's just sort of map
out sort of the objectives of what we
want to do so first we don't want to
make any invasive changes to primaries
second we want backups to exploit at
least as much parallelism as primaries
and finally we want backups to be able
to serve reads so we don't want to make
any big changes with the primary for
several reasons the first is that any
changes to help replication lag might
impact performance on the primary itself
right so for instance there's a lot of
academic literature on multi core record
and replay techniques which involve
logging low level scheduling locks and
like thread preemptions and whatnot
there also exists other mechanisms that
are often used in the real world such as
only acting back to a client when a log
record has actually been played back on
a backup and as you can imagine this can
significantly hurt performance now the
important point to note about hurting
performance on the primary is that the
reason you're seeing left replication
lag in the first place is because you
have a non-trivial amount of load on the
primary now if you decrease its ability
to handle this load it's not it's not
it's not a good it's not a good thing
finally it may turn out that the changes
to the primary themselves are changes
the primary are unnecessary because we
have all the information already in the
log we just need to make better use of
it so I'm not going to talk about the
backup parallelism problem and the basic
idea is to use the information in the
log to find out what actually happened
on the master write and as we'll find
out it's all about conflicts
now when I say conflicts I mean that
whenever two requests attempt to update
the same piece of data I refer to it as
a conflict right and I'll show that the
order in which requests occur
in which logger.log records are executed
only really matters for conflicts so
going back to our example the only
reason that we got this divergent state
here was that requests 2 & 3 both wrote
this object Z right and if you consider
this request for which rights object W
we could execute requests for in any
order relative to 1 2 & 3 and we'd still
end up with state w-4 right this would
be perfectly fine because it doesn't
conflict with anything so the basic
intuition for how to execute requests is
for conflicting requests execute them in
law of order and for non conflicting
requests log order is irrelevant so to
determine which execute of which log
records execution needs to be
constrained or we can perform a conflict
analysis on the log records so conflict
analysis is practical because the log
records have to declare what they need
to write I mean you literally have that
information in the log record because
that's what a log record is the and the
output of our conflict analysis could be
a directed graph of log records where
the edges determined constraints on
their execution so let's look at what
that might look like as an example so we
first look at the log record r1 we have
we haven't seen anything yet there's
nothing to do we look at a log record r2
we see doesn't conflict with r1 so it's
just is we then look at log record r3
now here we see that our three conflicts
with both r2 and r1 and hence its
execution needs to be constrained with
respect to r2 and r1 like r1 and r2 have
to execute before r3 finally we look at
R 4 and since it writes W doesn't
conflict with anything it's not
constrained in any way now given this
graph of log records it's quite easy to
execute them in a manner that is
consistent with the graph right all we
really need is that it's safe to execute
a log record once all its parents have
been executed that's it now the final
requirement of any solution to the
parallel replication problem is that
we'd like to be able to serve reads on
backups right this means that any read
should observe state that at
truly existed on the primary right now
we we can allow these reeds to be stale
because of the laws of physics right
it's impossible for the reeds to be
indistinguishable from those on the
primary because you physically have to
ship log records from the primary to the
backup now this point some of you may be
wondering if the primary and backups are
always guaranteed to converge correctly
with our conflict analysis
why would serving Reed's be difficult
and it's best to motivate this with an
example so say we have a social media
application where requests manipulate
albums and pictures so every picture we
want that every picture is always
associated with an album that actually
exists and this example talks about two
requests r1 which creates an album and
r2 which creates a picture now in the in
r2 score we also see that there's a
check that the that the album that the
picture references it checks that the
album in which the picture is going to
be put into actually exists and if this
check does it and if this check fails it
doesn't insert the picture right so as a
consequence there's this implicit
dependency on pictures and albums
furthermore because this implicit
dependency exists we can conclude that
it's impossible for r1 to ever occur
after r2 and for r2 to have inserted a
picture the reason is that if r2 inserts
a picture then it's necessarily observed
that album in on the primary state right
so it's impossible for r1 to happen
after r2 if r2 is going to insert a
picture now there are a couple of really
interesting things about this example
the first is that the two log records
don't conflict right they right separate
pieces of data so our conflict analysis
would conclude that they can be executed
in parallel so it's possible on while
replaying these log records that we
execute our two but not our one but the
problem in doing that is if we now
expose this state to a client then a
client could potentially see a state
where there's a picture without a
corresponding album right and this
breaks the applications invariant that
every picture is associated with an
album right so it's good
one of the interesting thing to note
here though is that executing requests
from the log in order will still
guarantee will guarantee that these
implicit dependencies are always
captured right um so one possible
solutions problem would be to also just
put implicit dependencies into the
conflict graph right if we could somehow
detect these implicit these implicit
dependencies you just put them in a
graph and we're done
but the problem is untenable because
it's really hard to detect the implicit
dependencies because they're very
application specific so in this case
this implicit dependency arose because
of code in r2 right but you could
imagine another mechanism to do this so
for example a client could synchronously
check that the album is going to insert
into actually exists and then only on
that check sort of succeeding sort of
does it perform the insertion now in
this case it's not even in the code so
there's no way to tell when these
implicit dependencies actually occur
it's very it's very application specific
right so so so this is so this is a this
is a serious problem right but as I said
before it turns out again that the order
in the log is key and implicit
dependencies will always be satisfied
when if we execute request in log order
so the solution here is to expose stated
reads when we have explicitly computed a
complete prefix of the log now it's
important to note that this doesn't
necessarily mean that we execute
everything serially right you could
still execute things in parallel but we
just have to wait but we just have to
wait for a complete prefix to be
executed right and I'll and I'll cover
in more detail in the next section how
we can actually achieve this in practice
which brings us to implementation so at
this point I'd like to discuss sort of
how we did on the ideal outcomes
so the solution sketch that I provided
doesn't really do it has no invasive
changes on the primary's backups can
exploit parallelism by doing this
conflict analysis of log entries and
backups can also serve reads by exposing
state to reads at complete prefixes now
there are two important implementation
questions I think which are important to
think about the first is that the
conflict analysis process I mentioned
is sequential and as a consequence that
might it might turn out to be a
bottleneck on a multi on a large
multi-core machine the second question
is how to actually ensure that we're
able to get complete prefixes
materialized while still executing log
records in parallel and it turns out
that the second problem is really
challenging
so to recap right we use the conflict
analysis to figure out the order in
which we need to execute log records
this is fairly straightforward to do
with a single thread right the thread
walks through the log records in order
and for each log record simply figures
out the immediately preceding set of
conflicting records that's it
now unfortunately since this is a single
thread it can turn into a bottleneck on
a machine with lots of CPU cores so what
we require to do somehow is to somehow
do this conflict analysis in parallel
and there's actually a very
straightforward way to do this we
basically partition objects across
various threads in your system and these
threads will only analyze the portion of
a log record that belongs to its
partition so every thread just maintains
a map from each object to its last
writer and we use this map to create
dependencies between log records so
let's look at what that might look like
in the context of our example in this
case we have a request one which writes
to both partitions you try to X and it
writes to Y so in this case both
partitions will insert this reference to
this log record in its map next we
encounter r2 and which only writes to Z
and in this case the its corresponding
partition will update its map now when
we see our three we notice that it
conflicts with both r1 and r2 and and as
a consequence like we can insert the
dependencies at this point it happens to
be the case that both y&z reside on the
same thread but you can totally imagine
this being done regardless of where the
actual objects reside once it does that
you update the map and we're done a
fairly straightforward process to
parallelize this analysis mechanism on a
multi-core machine so now let's switch
into how to execute reads on backups so
I previously established that the only
way to correctly expose state to
is when a complete prefix of the log has
actually finished executing however it's
unlikely that this will ever magically
happen just by itself right the problem
is that the conflict analysis let's log
records execute out of order right and
as a consequence there's no guarantee
that you'll ever get to a complete
prefix of the log being executed when
you know you get a constant stream of
new log records coming in for the
primary so let's let's take a look at an
example of what I mean so this shows the
order in which log records could
potentially be executed now we could end
up executing r1 r2 and r4 without
executing r3 right r3 could be executed
after r4 but this is perfectly fine in
and of itself right the problem is that
as you get new log records stream into
the backup it's not clear that sort of
you know this whole will not just be
moved to somewhere else somewhere else
in the log so it's not clear that you'll
ever actually get to a point in time
that we have a complete prefix now so
that it's that we have no hope in
waiting for complete prefixes because
it's just really hard to guarantee the
problem the the problem is that in order
to get a complete prefix you're probably
going to have to quiesce all your
updates in your system until you
generate that prefix and that obviously
is gonna hurt that ilysm because you're
constraining the number of requests that
can execute concurrently so instead we
weaken the requirement a little bit and
instead maintain a low-water mark of the
of a complete prefix so in this case we
see that requests r1 and r2 have
finished executing and this corresponds
to the low-water mark of a complete
prefix right so in this case the
low-water mark corresponds to r2 which
which which tells you about this the
longest sort of subsequence of the log
that's complete right and in addition we
use or we can use an incremental check
pointing mechanism to checkpoint state
corresponding to this complete partial
prefix of the log right now obviously
I'm glossing over a lot of details here
doing incremental check pointing is
really tricky without questing updates
but I'm not going to go into the details
in the stock so we're getting towards
the end of the presentation
and I just like to point out sort of
some of the inspiration of where we got
these ideas from so the conflict driven
pre scheduling was actually something
that was implemented in deterministic
database systems in 1997 so this was in
a paper called high-volume transaction
processing without concurrency control
two-phase commit sequel or c++ right and
the idea that these the idea in this
paper is to just eliminate
non-deterministic concurrency control
such as two-phase locking and instead
just do this conflict driven analysis
before executing transactions and the
idea was that this would give you far
better performance than doing the sort
of non-deterministic concurrency control
online so the idea for conflict for the
scalability of the conflict driven
rescheduling came about when I wrote a
paper on multi-version concurrency
control for a deterministic database
system this was in a paper called
rethinking serializable multi-version
concurrency control there was published
in 2015 now there's another issue to
this conflict driven scheduling one of
the issues is that the scheduling at the
granularity of a log record sometimes is
not enough you could still lag behind a
primary depending on the you can still
lag behind a primary depending on what
the primary does to guarantee
correctness so this talks this paper
talk about sort of fine-grained
scheduling of log records so this was a
paper that was published just this year
it was called high performance
transactions we are early write
visibility and finally since I gave
absolutely no details on incremental
checkpointing here's the paper that was
published in 2016 or called a low
overhead asynchronous check pointing for
main memory database systems the idea
here was to somehow get a consistent
checkpoint of a system without having to
quiesce all the updates right so
multi-core parallelism and replication
seemed independent and easy to combine
in practice it's like the scene in The
Big Lebowski where Walter and the dude
seem to think that it's easy to coerce a
teenager into admitting that he stole
the dude's car on being unable to coerce
the teen Walter has a complete meltdown
and destroys a random strangers car
right mágico
multicores and replication are similarly
easy to get spectacularly wrong even
though the problem seems relatively
innocuous
so in conclusion server code must
exploit multi-core hardware and remain
highly available via replication and it
turns out that these two goals are at
odds with each other this is because of
the non determinism inherent in parallel
programs however it turns out that
everything you need is in the log we can
use conflict information in the log to
get parallelism and we can use the order
of the log to ensure that implicit
dependencies between log records are
satisfied for reads this is something
that we're actively working on we're
both doing research and trying to build
this in an existing system so watch this
space
so I'm Joseph Alejo thank you for
listening but before I relinquish I want
to mention that I'm based out of San
Francisco and eager to learn about
examples of this issue in practice so if
you're experiencing issues with
replication lag I'm happy to meet up in
person and chat more thanks
[Applause]